[Music]
Harry Potter might be over but fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald brought
us back to researching Harry Potter
theories we might have missed stay tuned
to hear about an awesome theory about
Nagini
that has nothing to do with the zoo from
the first book don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to the
things now let's check out 10 Harry
Potter fan theories that changed
everything
Trelawney's prediction let's start off
with the character no one really liked
but she turned out to make quite a few
predictions that ended up coming true
let's face it we all thought Trelawney
was just a con artist until we learned
that JK Rowling never coincidentally
write something and everything connects
this one is a simple theory but it
should really change your opinion on the
divination professor do you remember the
very first divination class where
professor Trelawney tries to guess
Harry's birth month and gets it wrong
which makes people around chuckle well
one Koro writer pointed out that she
actually kind of was right now that we
know that Harry is a Horcrux she is
saying that Harry was born in midwinter
but we all know that he was born in July
well what if she was actually guessing
the age of his Horcrux or even
Voldemort's birthday we also know that
Tom Riddle aka Voldemort was born on
December 31st which is still considered
midwinter sure Lonnie did actually
foreshadow Harry being a Horcrux except
no one ever realized it knowing that we
have a feeling there are plenty of more
hints thrown our way as we reread the
book speaking of we bet you never saw
this hint coming the Dursleys sure
Lonnie's theory kind of connects to this
one so we all know that Harry's a
Horcrux and because of the last book we
also know that whoever's around a
Horcrux becomes miserable and can even
start picking fights a tumblr user
called graphic nerd to be pointed out an
interesting theory that will make you
look at the Dursleys in a completely
different light we all know the Dursleys
were completely mean and abusive to
Harry without any reason whatsoever
other than they really hated the magic
fool but what if their behavior relates
to the fact that they were living with a
Horcrux all this time of course some
people might say that this theory might
just want to make excuses for Dursleys
behavior and blame Harry but could it be
that their mood was also magnified by
the fact that Harry was a Horcrux the
theory was never confirmed by JK Rowling
and although it might be accidental
it does put things in a weird
perspective and definitely changes
everything
well everything except for the fact that
the Dursleys were just unapologetically
mean to Harry for all those years
what do you think of this one let us
know in the comments foreshadowing this
fan theory from a core user states that
the very first book had a lot of
foreshadowing in what's going to happen
in the end and the main link is for
Renza the Centaur who rescued Harry from
the very first Voldemort sighting the
centaurs are mad at Forenza for
interfering and say that it's written in
the stars a statement that is also later
confirmed by Harry we also know that in
the very final book when the battle
between Harry and Voldemort happened yet
again the Centaurs did nothing to help
and finally allowed the stars to do what
it was said in the prophecy they only
joined the battle once the news that
Harry had lost his life was being spread
the fan theory states that the sentence
it was written in the stars for shadows
what was meant to happen between Harry
and Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest
all along and we all know that Forenza
was banished from the herd for
interfering as well as helping
Dumbledore to plus it makes sense why
centaurs took a step back until the
prophecy was fulfilled another
foreshadowing from the first movie
occurs when Hagrid talks about
you-know-who and his whereabouts he
states that he doesn't believe he's
actually gone because he doesn't think
he had enough human left in him pray
these parents now this is an interesting
one a reddit user pointed out a possible
reason why Colin Creevey parents are
both muggles we all know that both Colin
and his brother are wizards which is
kind of strange considering they were
both muggles
there's no way two muggles would be able
to give birth to two wizards right well
Luna Lilliputians theory states that
their parents weren't actually muggles
they were squids actually given up by
pureblood families the user goes on to
say that their families put them up for
adoption and wipe their children's
memories because they were so
disappointed in them for not being able
to produce magic so they grew up in a
normal muggle environment and they never
remember
magic past at all we also know that
Colin's dad loves looking at pictures of
Hogwarts which could mean he's actually
trying to touch on a memory that's been
erased it could just be that when the
creepy parents met they were able to
awake part of the memory that was
suppressed which is probably why they
have such strong interest in magic even
though they can't really practice it
themselves the tale of the three
brothers this is a viral theory that's
actually pretty mind-blowing when you
think about it Deathly Hallows was full
of unexpected stories and turns
including the tale of the three brothers
which actually played a more important
part than we think the theory states
that Snape Harry and Voldemort are those
three brothers Voldemort represents the
oldest brother as he's the one that
seeks the most power only to ultimately
turn on him Snape is the middle brother
who can never stop thinking about his
past love his memory ends up being the
result of the end of his life which is
sort of what happens to Snape and then
there's Harry the youngest brother who
was sought by the end but it couldn't
get him until he went toward it
willingly that's kind of what happens in
the last book when Harry and Dumbledore
take a walk on what looks like the
platform nine and three-quarters so cook
Dumbledore represent death it looks like
JK Rowling is totally cheering on this
idea and says it really fits the entire
story you'll definitely never look at
Dumbledore again after this theory even
if you already know how the story ended
st. Mungo's one of our favorite theories
also involves a lot of foreshadowing
it's one of those that will make you say
I dunno but at the same time this could
actually be pretty interesting a Korra
user pointed out this crazy
foreshadowing idea from the fifth book
when Harry visits mr. Weasley in st.
Mungo's the theory is actually pretty
simple but it could actually foresee
something no one ever wanted to happen
st. Mungo's has awards such as creature
induced injuries dangerous die Llewellyn
Ward and serious bites but if you put
the first words of each of those things
together you actually get a statement
that reads creature dangerous die
serious if you say it three times fast
you can probably figure out that
Warren's hair
that creature is dangerous because he'll
be the reason why Harry's Godfather lost
his life what an interesting morning
considering both of these things happen
in the fifth book we have a feeling
there might be way more to this theory
than we think but unless you've actually
written out those words you'd never know
although we did have a feeling that's
exactly what JK Rowling did before she
wrote down that entire hospital scene
this theory hasn't been confirmed either
that it's our favorite because of its
detail ten points to Neville this one
actually makes a lot of sense as it
brings several theories together even
though it was never confirmed a Korra
user pointed out the reason why
Dumbledore gave Neville 10 points during
the first book when he stood up to his
friends we were all holding our breaths
to see if Gryffindor would win the house
cup and it all came down to just a few
points after our favorite trio got
theirs and that's when Dumbledore
acknowledged Neville and gave him ten
points but we all thought he was doing
this to include Neville and make him
feel part of the team this core a user
points out that Dumbledore knows the
value of standing up to his friends
because that's exactly what he had to do
with Grindelwald
speaking of Grindelwald our last theory
is incredibly interesting too but going
back to the ten points another core a
user also pointed out that Dumbledore
also knows the cost of not standing up
to your friends because we all know that
he also lost his sister in the process
so the ten points moment is actually a
lot more meaningful than you thought
well at least according to this fan
theory that seems to connect everything
together divination predictions her
mighty might have been wrong about
Trelawney and divination in general
because it turns out a lot of
predictions did actually come true after
all
JK Rowling never writes anything that's
not meaningful so knowing this a tumblr
user revisited the divination class
where harry and ron mess around with
their predictions in the Goblet of Fire
everyone just brushed them off because
quite honestly they didn't look like
much but in fact all of those
predictions actually came through if you
think about it they make up a lot of
stuff like Harry will be in danger of
burns he'll lose a treasured possession
he'll drown he'll get stabbed in the
back
by someone he thought was a friend and
he'll come off worse in a fight well
didn't all those things actually happen
he fought a dragon he lost Ron as his
best friend he was submerged in the
Black Lake his defense against the dark
arts professor stabbed him in the back
and he came off force in a fight after
his duel with Voldemort at the graveyard
sure they're a little far fetched but
hey you can't ignore this theory maybe
they all have psychic powers within them
and Trelawney was right all along
sorry Hermione Cruikshank's there are so
many favorite theories within Harry
Potter it's extremely hard to choose our
favourite one but this is definitely one
of the best ones
no one ever explained the story of
Crookshanks but fans have plenty of
theories this Korra user states that
Crookshanks has actually been around
longer than we think
Hermione's cat might have connections to
the cat that was owned by the Potters
since Harry's mother mentions they had a
cat in her letter
Harry wonders if the cat survived the
attack but of course the question is
never answered in the third book we also
find out that the owner of the pet store
had Crookshanks for quite some time
because no one wanted it Cruikshank's
also recognizes Scabbers aka Peter and
Sirius so could it be that Crookshanks
was actually the same cat that was owned
by Lily and James Potter it explains why
it would recognise Scabbers and Sirius
especially since they frequently visited
and probably transformed quite a lot
this theory was never confirmed but it
would be so nice to know that a part of
the Potter family has always been around
Harry all this time Nagini this harry
potter fan theory also relates to the
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald movie that's set to come out
in November 2018 it might explain the
origin of Nagini the snake and we all
know there are many unanswered questions
about that snake
we know that Nikki niece of Horcrux but
many suspect that the story behind
Nagini
is just slightly different all fingers
seem to point to maledictis a human
witch whose blood was cursed leading her
to turn into an actual beast when the
first fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald was released we caught a
glimpse of maledictis and theories that
she could be the original version of
Nagini quickly started to spread no one
seemed to have confirmed this but it
would make sense that a human which
became a beast and then for some reason
or made or a Horcrux so was Nagini
actually human with literal bad blood
that turned her into a beast sounds like
an awesome theory previous theories of
Nagini being the snake from the zoo we
saw in the first movie has also been a
subject of discussion none of these have
been confirmed but they're absolutely
mind-blowing to think about and that's
all for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and tell us how
you felt about this video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]